So let's start with the first formula we have to cover, which is if we look up true, concatenate,
trim, transpose and count it.
So I will mention some values, like name, contact number and team.
So let's start with the first formula we have to cover, which is if we look up true, concatenate,
trim, transpose and count it.
So let's start with the second formula we have to cover, which is concatenate,
So let's start with the second formula we have to cover, which is concatenate, concatenate,
So let's start with the second formula we have to cover, which is concatenate, concatenate, concatenate,
So let's start with our if condition,
So in that case, what we do is, for example, I have 90, 80, and so on.
So for 90, A is done. For 80, B is done.
If the child's grade percentage is 90 or above that, then A grade will come.
For 80, above that, B. For 70, above that, C. For 60, D and EF.
This is done for grading.
Or it can be done for pass fail as well.
If the child's grade is below 40, then 30% fails.
So in that case, what we do is, we have to enter the marks or values of the child.
Student name, then subject 1, subject 2, subject 3.
Three subjects are done.
The child's number is 20, 30, and 50.
This is the total.
And this is the grade.
This is the grade value.
And here, after 20, we have 30, 40, and 40.
This is the total.
We will sum these three.
100.
We will enter the values here.
30, 10, and 40.
This is done.
40, and 30.
I have made this situational by my own will.
To apply any condition.
10.
Now I will apply the grade formula.
Equal, if, sorry.
After if, bracket.
Equal, if, bracket start.
Logical test.
100.
This is greater than.
Equal to 90.
Grade 8.
Common.
This was if, bracket start.
This one equal to 15.
Grade B.
I will try.
I have applied two conditions.
If the total value is greater than 90, then A is printed.
If it is greater than 80, then B is printed.
Otherwise, false I.
Otherwise, we can print fail.
See.
Fail.
Now tell me if you have understood this.
Otherwise, I will brief you.
What have you done?
Or I will apply all the formulas.
Tell me one by one.
Akshat, Aman, Palak, Tanvi, Tinku.
Sir, brief one last one.
Okay.
Understand what I have done.
I have worked on these two values.
I have applied if condition.
This is grade.
I am taking an example.
This is the total of the child.
We have applied grade on this.
If the marks of the student.
Read this condition.
In total.
90 equal to 90 or greater than 90.
These are the symbols I have taken.
Okay.
Greater than equal to.
A print.
Or.
80.
That is equal to 80.
Or above that.
B print.
Otherwise.
Fail print.
So.
That condition has been applied.
If the marks of the student.
90.
Or above that.
A print.
80.
Or above that.
How much will it go above that?
It will go up to 90.
Okay.
If the marks of the student.
80 to 89.
89.5.
B print.
Otherwise.
In grade.
The same printing formula.
Has been applied.
The marks of the student.
90 or above that.
Means above 100.
So.
A print.
Here.
90 or above that.
90 means I have applied equal.
Even if there is 90.
A print.
So.
Now.
Here.
80.
Or greater than 80.
So.
B print.
It is equal to 80.
But.
There are no 90.
If there were 90.
A print.
So.
B print.
So below 80.
Then.
It seems that there is a mistake.
I haven't applied all.
I have only passed 2 print value.
Now.
I show the marks.
Up and down.
It is showing 80.
Okay.
I make it 70.
See this.
Fail print.
Because.
The condition I have applied.
Is written 80.
Then.
There is a problem.
Yes, sir.